tequila is the best shot to do on a
night out
I had to hear the shots last night
and I am regretting it you don't
strongly disagree that tequila took the
best shots no but then what is the best
shot I'm partial to the Jager Bomb oh
really because you get you know you get
the kick of the Red Bull there but the
best shot is in Australia and excuse my
language it's called a wet shop okay and
it is the most delicious shot it like it
has no one's mad about having a question
it's mainly vodka and then topped up
with peach schnapps a bit of cranberry
juice and a squeeze of lime no it's
delicious
the word schnapps just brings up like
too many memories I was um extremely
awkward when I first ordered one in
America though did they know what it was
no I just yelled the words wet